Mom and I are getting ready for the day.
This is my OG complexion stick.
My OG complexion stick right here.
This copper. We're both copying this line underneath.
Oh, wow.
I don't like my nose to be white,
so it's a little.
I like my neck glowy.
Glowy, glowy. Dewy. Dewy. Okay.
Dewy gold. And I started wearing it, and it wasn't a day or two,
and people were looking at me, and they were saying,
you look younger.
The bronzer? Yeah.
So I like.
Yeah, I like.
Oh, yeah,
I like that. So I'm using rose,
but I'm gonna try her toe test. Can I?
Okay,
so with this one,
these are my lips, too,
but I usually put a liner on first.
You like the pink better on your teeth?
I
don't like makeup under my brow.
It just makes it lift.
You lose their lips.
Did you put some on?
It goes on a little smoother.